you don't deserve that who do you think
you are young man the child 97 isn't
thinking oh i'm not doing well but i'll
do better and my father will be happy i
said no a child under seven not thinking
recording
i do not deserve
i am not lovable
i am not worthy you can reprogram the
subconscious mind instead of
disempowering programs you put in
empowering programs you put in wishes
and desires as a program oh i'm so sorry
i made you work hard there evan
bruce lipton welcome aboard great to
have you um man i've interviewed some
big names on my channel we've had people
like matthew mcconaughey and tony
robbins on three times and people sold
their businesses for a billion dollars
but
your content is probably what i spent
the most time on prepping for any
interview i've done on my channel oh i'm
so sorry i made you work hard there evan
no it's been amazing it's been such a
rabbit hole to dive down in and and
here's here's my struggle uh my heart
and my soul
agrees with you and loves everything
you're making
my brain is struggling to catch up
to some of the science behind it and i
know you're a scientist as your
background is that is that actually a
common thing when you're talking to
people like it feels right but they
can't make logical sense of it yet when
i do speak with them i hope i translate
it so that they understand what i'm
talking about otherwise i'm wasting
their time and my time so
over the years i think i've gotten it
down to public speak you know from
scientif when i first uh wrote my book
the biology beliefs the first part of
the manuscript got halfway done and i
thought you know i'm just going to give
it to some friends to see how it's
working and i gave it to some people to
look at and then i never saw them again
and i had to chase them down
and when i got to them they said well
bruce we didn't want to tell you we
didn't understand a damn word the hell
you were writing there because i was
using my scientific you know language
from the lab and i realized oh my god i
can't write a book using the science i
have to turn it into everyday speak
which took a little bit of time but it
did and happened and
it's pretty understandable at this point
because the significance is
knowledge is power
without this knowledge that i'm talking
about you are certainly don't have the
full power
that a human has in creating the world
that they live in well i love the effort
and consistency that you're creating the
show up and make content whether it's
the interviews or the full-on lectures
or the fun on your youtube channel with
your nephew doing all these different
skits is like any way possible try to
get the message out i appreciate
everything that you're creating well
this is why i'm here with you evan
because i also appreciate what you're
creating and i mean really for me this
is the opportunity to speak to your
audience while i talk to you directly i
know we have a following out there and
so you are
really supporting what i'm trying to do
but you're doing what you're doing is
what i want to support you doing because
the idea is
until we wake up uh this nightmare is
going to continue
and it is a nightmare uh the current
world's global chaos you know i mean
there's so much upheaval going on
everywhere
that there's no country that doesn't
have some upheaval experiencing uh right
now
and there's a reason for it and there's
an understanding and all of a sudden it
takes a mystery out makes sense out of
it and all of a sudden says oh yeah i
can thrive through this time period
because i i know what's going on right
knowledge is power that's what it comes
down to the say the same thing
but maybe more relevant to listeners is
a lack of knowledge is a lack of power
and the public has been systematically
deprived of some very important powerful
knowledge that could change their lives
um
again it's like the media is controlled
do they want you to be empowered they
who are they i don't know i just tell
you
i use a excerpt from michael moore's
movie uh called sicko and then there's a
parliamentarian tony benn a very liberal
parliamentarian in london
and he just straight looks in the camera
he says governments do not want a
healthy intelligent population because
they're difficult to control
and i go wow
you know i'm old enough
you know to have been here when the
united states was actually something
people wanted to live up to when years
ago you know
i'm
near 80
but i'm still enjoying it
but if i go back 70 years or so and i
can tell you we lived in a different
world at that time the us was a leader
in virtually every field whether it was
just the infrastructure of the country
the technology that we developed you
know the the government and the freedoms
that we had at that time
and i go today this is not the same
country anymore
and it's been taken over by corporate
interests
and corporations just see us as
customers
[Laughter]
and uh there they manipulate the world
that we're in
and it's an unfortunate situation
because people have lost their power and
corporations have usurped that power
so uh you know i give you a simple thing
we're supposed to be in a democracy and
i go what is that i go well hey
the public was asked do you want
background checks on people before they
buy a gun 90 percent said yes
and the government voted it down i go
well then who the hell are they
representing and go the nra they're not
representing us
and all of a sudden people don't realize
that this government is bought and paid
for and uh uh and we're just the victims
of the programming that we accept this
and go oh this is the way life is i go
no this is when life is being made
and you go what do you mean being made
and then i go
so it's important let's go right back to
ground zero here and ground zero is this
quantum physics is the most valid
science on this planet
and principle number one principle
number one from 1927 principle number
one consciousness is creating our life
experiences now max planck one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics uh
wrote that in 1927 he wrote the mind is
the matrix of all matter
this is where the movie the matrix got
its title from the mind is the matrix
the mind is the creator of all matter
that's that's exactly what the whole
idea was
and the idea well this is absolutely
true
except people don't recognize
uh
that we have also been programmed
and this is what the matrix movie is
about you're in a program and i go yes
we are we're living a program because
your mind just think about it
i tell you your mind is creating this
world and i say well look around to this
world you want to own that you've
created this and go no i don't
i don't want to do that the world is
crazy i go yeah because
um the idea
that uh your programs can control your
life
well that's not a new idea at 400
years old
the jesuits
would tell their followers
give me a child until it is seven and i
will show you the man
oh you know people didn't even
understand what the hell they were
really meaning by it but the truth is
simply this just before birth through
age seven is a programming period for
the brain it needs program it's a
computer
computer doesn't work without a program
once the programs are in then you could
add your data and then work with the
program but you get the programs first
and then i go well the jesuits knew this
the jesuits knew that whatever programs
you have in the first seven years that's
the programming period actually
uh they say the rest of your life
will be that program and they know
knew
what we now know
and that is
95 of your life is not coming from your
creative wishes and desires mind matrix
it's coming from the subconscious
programs so you're not living your life
you're living the program and so this is
exactly what the jesuit said give me a
child until seven and i will show you
the man meaning if you give me the first
seven years to program i'll show you the
rest of the life of that man
and i was like wow
that was really brilliant
and yet it's been manipulating us for
400 years because once they understood
if you can compro program the first
seven you own the rest of that person's
life they created something called
catholic school
and they program people to to to have
this catholic belief system in the first
seven years so that the rest of their
lives even if they don't want to go to
church or not the belief system is
whatever that program was in the first
seven years and i go well this is a fact
for 400 years yes we are programmed in
the first seven years
what people are not paying attention to
is the programming has gotten much more
sophisticated than when the jesuits saw
it 400 years ago you i mean you see an
infant who could barely walk
carrying an ipad around uh you have to
recognize well there's some hell of a
program going on right there so yeah
we've been programmed 95 percent of our
life comes from the program these are
scientific facts
and that unfortunately
when we play a program we're playing it
because we're not paying attention
that's why the automatic programming
from the subconscious steps in it's like
autopilot
if we're thinking
then the conscious mind which is
creative mind
is not
looking out the windshield so to speak
like your body's a vehicle and we're
driving i say who's the driver i say the
conscious mind i go where is it driving
us to wishes and desires that's where we
want to go
like oh that's great and then i said but
what if the conscious mind is thinking i
go oh
why
because to pay attention you look out
the
window but thinking
is inside
so the moment you are in thought
you're not looking out the window
i say oh this could be very critical
you're driving the car and all of a
sudden you start thinking then your
conscious mind is not looking out the
window you're going to be a hell of a
lot of trouble i go
the subconscious mind is autopilot it
steps in
so whenever we're thinking
the conscious mind lets go of the vision
is inside seeking
whatever and while that mind is thinking
the behavior that is playing is coming
from programs that we got before age
seven
and since ninety five percent of our
life is the amount of time we spend
thinking that ninety-five percent of
your life is actually coming from your
programs and not coming from your
creative wishes and desires
and this is exactly again what the with
the jesuits told us it's a fact it is
true
and so the movie the matrix is
interesting because
max planck's statement the mind is the
matrix of all matter is saying that the
mind is the creator of all matter that's
the fact of principle of quantum physics
the most valid science that
the mind is creating this okay
and i go well this is real interesting
except that when people look at the
world around they they go i wouldn't
create this
and the fact is
they don't see themselves as creators
and i go why not i go
when they're thinking they're not
looking out the window the autopilot
steps in the autopilot plays a program
right
did the conscious mind see the program
no it was busy thinking so whatever
program was coming out
the conscious mind didn't see it because
the reason they were playing the
programs the conscious mind wasn't
paying attention so all of a sudden i
said well then here's the issue
yes 95 of your life you're creating your
life from your programs i go
but you didn't those programs that you
got
you got them from observing other people
mother father family a community that's
where you learned your behavior from by
observing them and then all of a sudden
comes the issue is like
well
did they uh create were they creating
the life that you want i go no well then
i say well you got a problem because
your behavior is controlled by their
creation now
okay
and the fact is
most every one of us have up to 60
percent of the programs that we
downloaded
are self-sabotaging and disempowering
beliefs
and i say so what's the result they go
geez you don't get it
we play programs 95 of the day because
that's the time that we're thinking but
because we're thinking we don't see the
programs that are playing they're just
coming straight out of the download and
i go significant as well
those people we downloaded from didn't
necessarily want to go where i want to
go so as long as i play their programs
i'm not going where i want to go
okay
and since i'm not observing the programs
because they're playing while i'm
thinking then if there are negative
behaviors up to 60 percent uh then we
will be playing those negative behaviors
and we won't be seeing it i say well why
can't you see your behavior and i say
because you're thinking you're not
looking out at the behavior so all of a
sudden i go well then the problem is
we perceive ourselves to be victims of a
world that doesn't support us
and i go well what does it mean when you
just say victim the first thing is this
powerless
and all of a sudden i say we all believe
we are powerless
in affecting the world around us without
recognizing we were creating the world
around us
but then if the programs don't support
us then then our life experiences are
filled with things that don't support us
and then all of a sudden it goes well
wait a minute
uh if i'm the creator then
i've got to change those programs
because these programs are disempowering
at every level
and the idea of biology belief is an
awakening
to the reality there's a mechanism that
explains this
there's a mechanism that defines why
you have trouble creating the life you
want when you are in fact the creator of
that life
and if you understand knowledge is power
then all of a sudden you understand how
powerful you are
but you have to then recognize well then
you have to exercise that power by what
get out of the damn program here and
take that damn red pill
you know and it's interesting because
life is like the movie the matrix the
movie the matrix everybody's programming
that was required in human development
everybody's program so that's true about
the movie
but in the movie they say you can take a
blue pill or a red pill you take the
blue pill you wake up and the world's
just the way it's always been but if you
take the red pill
you get out of the program and the whole
story starts to talk about getting out
of the program but it doesn't really
relate to us in this way and i go
almost all of us
have taken the red pill and it was
profound changes in our lives and you
didn't even know it i go what was i say
when we fall in love
it is recognized biologically
that when we fall in love we stop
thinking and stay present a simple
reason is this if you're thinking you're
not paying attention to what's going on
if you just fell in love with somebody
why would you want to not be there with
them so you stop thinking you stay
mindful
well that's the red pill because it was
your thinking that caused you to go into
the program but if you stop thinking
that's the red pill so love is the red
pill i go so what i got your life is
blah blah blah blah blah you meet
somebody
24 hours later
oh life is so beautiful
everything is beautiful
the food is wonderful the meal even the
crappy job it's beautiful i go
but that'll happen in 24 hours
you stop playing the program
and then life is now coming from not the
program but from the conscious
creativity
and the conscious creativity the
conscious mind has wishes and desires i
say evan tell me what you want in this
life and i go
the answer is coming from the creative
conscious mind that's the creative part
the subconscious programs
conscious is what do i want i go oh
so you can visualize what you want i go
yeah but your life is not coming from
that visualization because 95 of it's
still coming from the program you
download it back here
so the idea is
if you stop thinking then you don't
default to the autopilot
and therefore now your life is not run
by programs it's run by wishes and
desires
and i say yeah blah blah blah blah fall
in love 24 hours later heaven on earth
oh
if you only knew how that happened
then guess what with that knowledge you
can just say well how come the honeymoon
ends first of all i go the honeymoon
ends because
it's very hard to stay mindful without
thinking because the world has so many
demands on us and the moment you start
thinking guess what you start playing
the programs i go why is that a problem
i go
well those programs never played when
you fell in love when you fell in love
you were playing wishes and desires
but you start thinking all of a sudden
these programs from the back come out
now it's not your behavior it's your
mom's your dad's your community
and all of a sudden i say significance
your partner
in the relationship never saw the
programs until you start thinking
and all of a sudden i go why because if
they saw some of those programs they
probably wouldn't have been with you in
the first place but when you stopped
playing them you became the real person
you wanted to be
but once you start thinking you revert
back to programming that you got from
other people that your partner probably
i wouldn't want to associate with that
person i said what does it lead to i
said it leads to arguments because the
behaviors throw a monkey wrench in the
relationship and then 50 of these
relationships end up in divorce
i go you know during the honeymoon
period
there was no problem with divorce
happening then
but when the honeymoon ended because
thinking came in then the subconscious
program started to show up
and they threw the monkey wrench in the
machine
so if you could stay conscious forever
then you can be the creative
but
it's really hard in a world where people
depend on thinking of what you've done
where you're going where you will go you
know what you're doing all this is
thinking
uh and the moment you start going into
the thinking then
you're back into the program again so
much to unpack inside of that
let's dive into manifestation my
audience entrepreneurs small business
owners maybe live more in the world of
business plans and marketing projections
and spreadsheets and venture capital uh
so when you say stop thinking it's like
what did he just say so
how do how do those people who may not
be used to manifestation yet
how can you start to manifest a change
in your life okay now the first thing is
this
as a jesuit soldier and as it's true by
science
uh and it's 400 years old
it's the programs in the first seven
years of your life that actually started
even in the last trimester before you
were born the fetus is already learning
i go
these programs download in the first
seven years control the character of
your life
and i go okay
what programs did you get i go well wait
a minute
what program did you get what before you
were born it's like
i don't know like
i said okay what programs you were
programming a whole year from zero to
one
what programs did you get
oh i don't know
okay from one to two another whole year
of programming what program is it
i don't know
from two to three i don't know then all
of a sudden i say
your life is run by programs and you
have no conscious awareness of these
programs because your conscious mind
wasn't working
when the downloads were occurring
so all of a sudden i said now we have a
problem i go you've been programmed you
don't even know what the hell the
programs are and i go
this is the cool part evan
ninety-five percent of your life is
coming from the programs
your life is a printout of your programs
and i go so what does that mean i say
well look at your life right now
and recognize the things that you like
that come into your life they didn't get
there by accident they came in there
because you have a program to you know
have those things
but and this is the one i need people
listen to
the things that you wish or desire but
you have to work hard sweat over it put
effort into it you know i'm working on
it i'm going to make it i'll work on it
i go
why are you working so hard and the
answer is
whatever program you downloaded doesn't
support that
and you're trying to override the
program with the conscious mind and i go
well here's the problem
the conscious mind only working five
percent the program 95 that's one
problem right there mathematically
that's a problem let me give you another
mathematical the subconscious is one
million times more powerful a computer
than the conscious mind
so i say now do the math
how effective is your conscious mind at
overriding the subconscious i say it
works five percent of the time with a
miniature computer and i go wow that's
your problem i go
the only way you can override the
program is not play the program that's
when we said stay mindful and then we
then say well that's going to be
difficult because
we have to think
so there's only one way out
no no don't keep it a secret tell
everybody there's only one way out
reprogram the subconscious mind
and i go significance
if you would put wishes and desire
programs into the subconscious mind
that means that that program would be
operating 95 of the day
meaning
whether your conscious mind is in
control saying these are my wishes and
desires or the conscious mind's thinking
then the subconscious mind comes in and
said these are my wishes and desires
then guess what then 100 of your life
your living wishes and desires
and therefore all of a sudden then the
the the work has to come back to each of
us as individuals
each of us got programmed each of us is
manifesting that program we give up our
power in many of the programs the fine
example is
you were sick as a kid and just like
your parents and any other family
members when you were sick you went to
the doctor
and i go that's a habit i said what does
it mean it says you learn this in the
first seven years a program it says when
you're sick you give up this power and
you go to that doctor and you accept the
doctor as the power
of over you because when it came to
health it's like no no you don't do it
the doctor doesn't that's the program i
say so what's the point
you have given up power over the control
of your life and have given it to the
truth quote unquote offered by the
doctor i go significant i go
the doctor misreads your diagnosis
and then tells you oh i'm sorry you only
have three months left to live
and i go
significance
95 of the day the program says the
doctor is
the you know
the correct one the truth what do i know
the doctor knows what do i know
so 95 of the day then your belief system
is going to do what take the words of
the doctor and manifest them as truth
i go what's that mean
well you're going to die in about three
months i go from what i go hey that was
a misdiagnosis you're still going to die
because your belief system will manifest
an illness
that will terminate the cancer for
example is not due to any genes there's
no gene that causes cancer
the genes are correlated with cancer and
i go what causes cancer i say disharmony
and repressed anger is one of the big
ones
i go so then i say the genes didn't cost
i say no
so i said then what caused it i saved my
consciousness
i say what repressed anger
you know and i go so what i say we'll
change consciousness and guess what
you can go into remission
the cancer will go away as soon as you
change the consciousness
and all of a sudden it's like i thought
i was a victim of the genes i said
that's a program
and that is totally incorrect
because as quantum physics says
consciousness is creating our life
experiences as the new biology which i'm
familiar with called epigenetics is how
consciousness controls the genetics
and all of a sudden i say oh well then
biology and quantum physics now share
the same story yeah you're creating this
and the idea is that if you look at the
creation you're not happy with it don't
go out and blame the creation
because you never saw that you were
participating in a way invisible to you
that led to this expression
if you want to change it you have to
change you
and then the environment will change
so let's use me as an example through
this so when i was younger i brush my
teeth really hard
and as a result i have like really bad
receding gums and like i brushed away
some of my tooth right so the dentist
say it's never gonna grow back you're
gonna have to get your teeth repaired at
some point in your life so so if i'm
going to
you know if so if i'm going to heal so
you know i can heal that according to
bruce lipton in science i can heal that
correct 100
okay 100
so what do i do what like even if we
want to like live demo what am i
actually doing to start to change the
product well what you're doing is first
of all is you're taking a program of
what you're disempowered you can't do
this the gums won't repair the teeth
won't repair and that's a program i said
well if you buy that program and then
you put that in your mind just so so
joshua said whatever the program is that
becomes the rest of your life so you put
in a program that says i'm powerless
over the controlling of my teeth and my
gums i go no you're not you have stem
cells they'll replace all the damn gum
that you think you've lost in there i
said well why aren't they replacing it
oh because the program says i can't i
said
then what do i got to change i say you
have to take the can't the program and
say i can
and the issue is that's a program it's
not your conscious mind conscious mind
sitting back there going man this is a
terrible situation
uh
and i go because the conscious mind is
not realizing
that the manifestation is actually a
process of the subconscious mind they're
not talking to each other okay
and so the idea is this
you have stem cells what is the stem
cell it's an embryonic cell the body is
filled with stem cells say why
the body has is made out of 50 trillion
cells okay
i always love it because trillion is
like
how big is a trillion you know
a million is a lot but trillions are a
lot more
like how much is a lot more
it's hard for people to to manifest the
idea of what a trillion is a a trillion
uh here's a fact
take a dollar bill take a trillion
dollar bills and line up end to end to
end to end
okay
i said well how long is a line of a
trillion dollar bills
97 million miles
it's like
huh
that's a lot of dollar bills man 97
million miles and i say that's a
trillion you've got 50 trillion cells
okay that's 50 times 97 million miles
ago that's billions of miles
long
okay so i say the trillions a lot you
got 50 trillion cells but every day
hundreds of billions of your cells die
normal attrition
skin cells slough up
the lining of the digestive tract
trillion cells is replaced every three
days
and i go the skin
everything in the body can be replaced
gums 100
well then why am i not replacing my gums
i say
what are you telling yourselves i cannot
replace the gums i said where'd you get
that from i got well you got that from
the dentist program i go oh
guess what
you're not going to replace the guns why
you're telling yourself 95 of the day i
can't do it
and all of a sudden you have to change
the belief system and say wait a second
that was a bunch of bs uh meaning belief
system okay uh and i say you bought the
belief system and belief controls your
life and i say well if you bought the
fact that you won't grow your gums and
the fact is this you won't grow your
gums 95 of your life don't do it
and the idea is you want it to grow back
i say yeah you want to grow back well
then you have to get out of the damn
powerless program that you were put into
when you were being programmed
okay
and you have to rewrite these programs
and if you rewrite the programs you're
rewriting the whole character of your
life you know what's interesting
there's a great movie called regarding
henry
harrison ford stars in it
and he is a uh a professional he's a
lawyer and he's like a hard one of those
shark lawyers you know he's go out there
and get him shark lawyer
and um
he goes into a convenience store to get
something and there's a hold up he gets
shot and the head he loses his memory
and then now he's coming from amnesia he
doesn't know who he is so
he reviews his life through looking at
the court case files that he was
involved in and looking at the pictures
and whatever data and he realizes
i don't want that life
so what does he do
he created a new vision
and he walks away at the end of the
movie
a happy family guy and love and life and
all that why because he looked at in a
point of amnesia he'd look back and say
who was i
and then he thought about it says i
don't want to be that guy i want to be
this guy and he became that guy does
that mean we have to all get bullets in
the head
before we write the programs i go
fortunately not
although the nra would probably love it
because they sell hell a lot more
bullets but
the reality is no
you can reprogram the subconscious mind
uh and if you do so then guess what
instead of disempowering programs you
put in empowering programs
you put in wishes and desires as a
program
and i said then what's the consequences
that 95 of your life is coming from
those programs not the one that you
started with
so you can rewrite the whole path of
your life now regarding henry he did it
but at the expense of getting a bullet
to erase who he was so that he can build
and knew who he was
but you don't have to get the bullet you
can rewrite the programs in the
subconscious mind but there's a
technology and that's where the whole
thing falls apart because
the conscious mind and subconscious mind
are two different mindset
are interdependent they work with each
other okay
and the significance about it is that
the subconscious mind is just
data programs like a hard drive and a
computer and you downloaded them and
they're there and they
become autopilot all this time
and i say so the two minds are different
the conscious mind is creative the
subconscious mind is habit
program
conscious mind creative yes wishes and
desires
imagine conscious minds imagination
which we then can manifest
want to go to the moon the you know
people in the 1600s it'd be great to go
to the moon but it took some technology
and now going to the moon
is a reality what was imagination but we
can manifest it but first you have to
have the imagination
okay
so then i go i said well then let's look
at our human lives and i go
we have a conscious mind that has
imagination unfortunately it only works
five percent of the time
and that ninety-five percent of time our
life is actually coming from programs
from subconscious mind i say so the
difference is conscious mind creative
subconscious mind program
well they also learn in different ways
and this is where the monkey wrench gets
thrown into the machine i go well wait i
say conscious mind is creative i say
well then you can learn any damn way you
like
watch this podcast go go to a lecture
read a self-help book you can just go
aha
and you can change your conscious mind
but and here's where the difference
comes from
subconscious mind is programmed habit
let me go significance
if habits just changed like the
conscious mind then there would be no
habits
and i go but we need habits and i go
well there are good habits and there are
bad habits i said well that's where the
problem comes from i said let me give
you a good habit
evan
when did you learn how to walk
pretty early i don't know two when did
we learn how to walk just be before two
and i said guess what you're still
walking yes you have to relearn it nope
how long can you hold it you can be 100
years old and still walk i say it's a
habit you learned it the function of
that subconscious mind download the
habit and not change it
what if you woke up one day and just
forgot how to walk well then you'd be in
deep doo-doo at that moment because it's
like now what i said well then spend the
rest of your day trying to learn how to
walk
but once it's a program
you don't have to change it but habits
by the nature of them do not want to
change so all of a sudden i say well i
got bad habits they were downloaded by
observing the habits of my dad my mom my
family my community i download their
habits and they're my program but i said
well these are bad programs i said well
here you got a problem i say why
their habits
they don't want to change
i go well then how can i change i say
well
interestingly we can go back and say
when did you get the damn habits and
then understand how you got them so i'd
say oh
the first seven years of a child's life
brain activity is measured electrical
activity putting wires on a person's
head eeg
the brain activity of child under seven
is not at the predominant level of
consciousness it's at a lower vibration
that vibration is called theta
now a child
through age seven is mixing the real
world in the imaginary world because
theta is imagination
okay
and they mix the two so
you know the the kid is riding a broom
why in the mind
that imagination is it's not a broom now
it's a horse
to the degree that the mother says give
me the broom and the kid looks like what
are you talking about because it's not a
broom it's a horse
theta imagination but theta is hypnosis
so i say well relevance i say the brain
is a computer and like any computer
you can boot it up but if you don't have
a program
we can't use a damn pro you can't use a
computer i say oh so we buy a computer
we put the programs in the computer and
once the programs are in there we can
access the computer through the keyboard
that's conscious mind
now typing on the keyboard working with
the program built inside
i go what about if the conscious mind is
thinking it's not typing
well if it's not typing then where's the
behavior coming from the hard drive
it'll play without
it's automatic it's a habit
our programs 95 are from the habits that
we acquired in that first seven years
when we're in theta you want to change
those habits well then how did you get
them you were in theta
theta is below consciousness the moment
like when you go home and you're
sleeping the moment you fall asleep the
instant you fall asleep
the brain goes from alpha higher
vibration the moment you fall asleep it
drops into theta which is the vibration
of hypnosis
like oh
so if i put a pair of earphones on at
night as i'm going to bed
and i play a program in there that
you know conceptualizes my wishes and
desires you know relationship health job
something i want
i say you put the earphones on you might
hear it while you're awake and alpha but
the moment alpha shuts down you're
sleeping
but the theta
brain hypnosis is recording
whatever is going through those
earphones is not going into the
conscious mind it's going into the
subconscious so you play the program
every night for a number of nights
and one day you wake up and guess what
you got reprogrammed when when you were
sleeping you know what's cool it
required no conscious effort as a matter
of fact
put the conscious asleep because the
brain will then download this into the
subconscious because that's how it puts
programs in okay yeah if i'm gonna
change the prognosis right let's take
the three months you're gonna die and
instead flip it to hey my own medical
prognosis in three months my gums are
gonna be healed right if that's the new
program i'm trying to create yeah is it
is my next step then to record me saying
that and then play it on loop when i'm
sleeping yeah now here's the problem
because you said in three months i will
have this back and i go very important
fact ready
the subconscious mind doesn't have time
it has programs
i say
just not talking to your conscious mind
but talk to your subconscious program i
said when did you learn how to walk and
the answer would be
today
i go what do you mean i say
there's no clock that said this happened
back here it's just a program it's here
today
so i say so significance there's no
clock i go so what i say what if i write
i will be healed in three months and i
say good record that that's a program i
will be healed in three months
and let's come back a year
from now
push the button and say let's what what
does it say it says i will be healed in
three months i go oh
you never programmed you were healed you
only programmed you will be healed
which means you're never going to get
healed because that's not healed so the
most important part of putting a program
into the subconscious mind is that it
has to be put in in what is called
positive present tense
okay
instead of saying
i am healed
you say i am healthy
i go so why i say because now the
program is i am healthy i guess the
significance
the brain then looks around goes oh my
god no i'm not healthy now what's the
function of the brain
turn that
belief into reality you will heal
yourself that's a placebo effect in a
sense you've got a vision i will heal
myself that's what placebo effect is so
i take the sugar pill i heal myself it
wasn't the pill it was the belief i will
heal myself so if you put in programs
that are positive present tense you
can't say i will i shall i want those
are futures that never can go happen
subconscious doesn't tell past and
future it's just program
if you want to change the program you
don't put a future or tense to it at all
it has to be
my gums are healthy
not my gums will heal
because then you're focusing on the
illness
if you focus on my gums are healthy
there's no illness involved it's healthy
so
in rewriting programs that you brought
up evan this is the most important part
the subconscious is present tense only
it has no future or past
if you want to change something it has
to be as if it already has happen
i uh
i'm in uh i i love my relationship i
love my partner i love myself
80 to 90 of people in workshops where we
do belief change stuff that i get
involved with
will not
test positive for i love myself
and i go so what does that mean
well what if somebody comes up and they
try to say i love you
what's your subconscious got in mind
it's gonna say it's going to go
what's wrong with them
they don't know i know i'm not lovable
what's wrong with them
and the fact is
then to manifest the program i'm not
lovable
you will unconsciously push that person
away unconsciously i say so what's real
so i said down the road all of a sudden
that person's not there and guess what
you're going to say
i knew i was unlovable
i go with you just push them away that's
why
and so
to me why that's one of the most
important beliefs we need to change is
because
without love on this planet this is a a
bad trip this isn't why you're here
and uh if you have a program i'm not
lovable i said where the hell did that
come from i go
parents
act like coaches on the team trying to
help you grow up like what does that
mean i say a player on team is sloughing
off and the coach comes up and the coach
doesn't go oh please do better no the
coach comes up and says that's not good
enough who do you think you are you
don't deserve to be on this team
well a player who is older than seven is
consciously oh yeah the
coach is causing me that i gotta work
better that's so great
the sports player works better
but i say when a parent acts as a coach
and the child is under seven
the child's not in consciousness the
child is in subconscious
and subconscious is record
so when a child is hearing from their
dad you don't deserve that who do you
think you are young man
then i say
the child under 7 isn't thinking oh i'm
not doing well but i'll do better and my
father will be happy i say no a child
under seven not thinking recording
i do not deserve
i am not lovable
i am not worthy when i go these are
things that parents say to a child under
seven with the intention of being a
coach
saying if i say this to my kids they'll
do better i go if the child's under
seven
they're not conscious
they're just recording
and so i said then go back and look at
our programs as kids and you'll find
much of the criticism
is self-critical because it's a program
i'm not lovable that's a program
i'm not deserving that's a program and i
go if your life is running 95 of the
program and you say i'm not deserving
then guess what your behavior will
conflict
with your future
causing a problem which then you look at
and say i didn't get it
i didn't you know apparently i don't
deserve it i didn't get it i go
it was because the invisible program
saying you do not you do not deserve
will create behavior to manifest the
truth i do not deserve
and then you won't get it okay
so
big point about this is
then the behaviors that we got come in
take over 95 of the time
that most of them take away personal
love which is why 50 or more marriages
end up in divorce because
they got together when their conscious
minds were not using the subconscious
program
and then they split up when the
subconscious comes in place a crappy
program so then the thing falls apart
and then they'll go out and look for
another relationship and replay the same
damn thing again until
the program has changed
and that takes us back to
program changing i say well one way was
self-hypnosis earphones on at night go
to bed and play it a number of times
because theta's a short period before
you fall into deep sleep so you play it
and play it again play it again play it
again every night for a number of nights
and you'll get it in there and it'll
work okay
a second way of putting programs is well
after age seven you still learn programs
i mean you learn how to drive a car
you may learn how to play an instrument
you know i say these become habits
you when you get in the car you don't
have to remember like the first day
where you were just like
windows mirrors engine sounds gear shift
floor pedals oh my god you know it's
like now you get in the car you put the
key and you don't even think about the
mechanism
i failed my driving test seven times
bruce just so you know it took a long
time for that program to set in but yeah
there there was an issue about putting
that
in a pre-program that said no
so i said well how did you learn after
age seven because you're not in hypnosis
i say
we learn by repetition
that was the whole idea practice you
want to drive the car you damn well
practice it now hopefully you don't have
a program that cancels your ability by
saying you're not good enough or you
don't deserve this or something because
that will throw a monkey wrench in that
learning but the fact is this
how did you get new programs and i said
repetition
and i go so that means if i
repeat something in my head enough i can
manifest and i go yup
but you have to repeat it enough
that it becomes a program that overrides
an existing program that doesn't get you
to that point
you can't just erase a program but you
can supersede it with a new program okay
the new age talk
always makes me laugh when i think about
it the new ways to talk is fake it till
you make it and what the hell does that
mean i go well you're not a happy person
all day long
i'm not happy and i said well what if
you turn this around all day long you
just say i'm happy i am happy you're
you're not necessarily happy that wasn't
the point it was the repetition
i am happy i am happy i am happy i go oh
that's creating what a habit then i say
what happens when the habit's in guess
what you wake up one day you don't have
to say i'm happy program's already in
you woke up happy at that point okay
so those are two ways to take programs
that you have
that are not supporting you to put new
ones in self-hypnosis
repetition and then there's a third wave
which is the most amazing thing in this
world at this time is called energy
psychology it's different than the
previous versions of psychology like
talk therapy and all that stuff
energy psychology doesn't even go back
in history it doesn't give a damn how
you got a program it just says you're
planning a program
if you want to change the program change
the program do i have to go back and and
tell you how i got this program you know
that's irrelevant
there's an old saying don't kill the
messenger over the message
the program is message who
caused the irritations that led to the
program that's the messenger so you can
go back and beat up all those people
yeah my father did this my mother did
the blah blah blah
they're not the problem the problem is
you're carrying a program
so do i have to go back and find out how
i got to say that's irrelevant you
already know what the program is i said
what look at your life
you're not having a relationship we got
a bad program for a relationship
okay so i go do i have to go back and
find out how and it's not relevant i
have the program now
so i said oh so energy psychology
engages a concept called super learning
uh super learning is very interesting
you know some people read a book uh the
you know they'll open a book and then
they'll move their finger down the page
just like this
and they'll read every word on that page
just as fast as i did this boom i read
every word on the page that's super
learning experience
i go if you can engage super learning
and use that moment to download a
program
you can rewrite beliefs that you've held
your whole life
10 15 minutes
but it's a super learning process and so
there's a you got to get into that that
process and energy psychology there's
about 25 or more different versions of
energy psychology on my website under
belief change
and website bruce lipton.com very simple
uh and so i say yeah there are three
ways to change belief okay
self-hypnosis earphones on at night
repetition create a new habit
and third one energy psychology which
allows you to rewrite an existing
program in minutes
and we need to do this why
because if you haven't noticed and you
haven't looked out the window the
world's falling apart now they go and
why is it falling apart and the answer
is because we're facing what is called
the sixth mass extinction of life the
web of life is collapsing i go then why
this is the web of life collapsing
interest human behavior
i go oh
you don't want the web to
collapse
we have to change the behavior
and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time
the chaos all over the world is bringing
to light the fact that these behaviors
were
fighting and violently with are
behaviors that have taken us out of
heaven and put our consciousness into a
world that we're experiencing which is
falling apart
you want to make a world of heaven then
you change the program and then you
could have heaven
it's your belief system that creates
this you fell in love because you
stopped playing your program and you
created heaven
i say well guess what heaven was always
there except the damn program gotten
away
so you want heaven on earth
don't play the program stay mindful or b
rewrite the existing program and put
heaven on earth programs in there and
then 95 of the day you'll be playing
that
am i going like blah blah blah blah or
am i saying something out there no i
love it listen i mean i know and we're
already at time i think i got through
five percent of my questions but okay
let's go for them let's do the uh okay
the shoot down let's ask the question
answer fast
no this has been great because i love
this this is really um you know watching
your other interviews and videos and
this has really kind of really cemented
my knowledge and i'm gonna have to watch
us back and start to apply it uh even
just within those three things i mean i
get number one so
theta you know i can record a program
that could be at sleep that could also
be meditation there's other forms of
theta as well for the
uh the second one of repetition is that
just me
again practical example my gum so am i
using the positive
positive present tense again to say you
know my gums are healthy 40 times a day
and like reminders on my phone like how
am i staying consistent on that what's
what's the habit well the habit is your
current reality is an expression of the
habit that's why i say your your
downloaded habits are playing in front
of you right now you have trouble
getting those gums to clear up well then
there's a belief system that says you
can't do it and i go well that's quite
unfortunate because your stem cells can
replace any damn thing in your body at
any time
okay and all of a sudden but my stem
cells aren't working i go because your
consciousness is not encouraging them to
do that your your consciousness says you
can't do that and i say oh well then if
you can't do it then that's you just
told the cells don't do it not that they
couldn't do it you're just telling them
don't do it because you can't it's like
well that's not true but you're playing
the program
and so
uh
you have to put a new program and you
have to put in a belief system that my
my gums are healed that's a simple
statement my gums are healthy actually
it's better my gums are healthy
that's the end destination you want
my gums are healed i realize that
wouldn't i wouldn't say that one i would
say my gums are healthy that's the end
destination so i have to put in a
program of the end destination not how i
got to it i just have to put the picture
in if when i'm there what is it
that's basically what it's all about to
do that
it is so profoundly important
because
less than one percent of disease on this
planet is connected to genes
well that's a big issue because all of
our trying to treat the body with
disease is to affect the genes and i was
like yeah but the source wasn't the
genes the source was consciousness
and so all that medication all that
other stuff
again that's bs
you don't need the medication you need
the consciousness
the consciousness overrides medication
anyway
so the the point about it is
when we change our consciousness we
change our lives physically and
behaviorally a great example great
actors
i said what does that mean they take a
role on i say what's a role it's another
person's life they read it they this i'm
going to behave as this person
i said well then you're taking on what
the characters of that person
so example renee zellweger she's great
and she plays uh
uh i forgot you know the
diary or some damn thing because
princess thing i don't know what the
hell she played this uh part in the
movie bridget jones
i guess so what say well bridget jones
is 40 pounds heavier than
renee and has these characteristics
well
renee takes that character
and and plays it and plays it
and plays it and guess what she becomes
bridget jones she gained 40 pounds
because that was the character okay
now comes the cool part
movie's over
no more character boom she's back to
renee guess what she loses to 40 pounds
the the biology accommodated the belief
system
and so i said well that's true i mean
dustin hoffman great actor plays willie
lohman a very depressive character in
death of a salesman
and he's so good at it
that
while playing it on broadway and
repeating this
he ended up going to a neurological
hospital
because his depression was so great he
couldn't he couldn't he wasn't healthy
anymore he had to go to a hospital to
stop playing the character that he
manifested
okay
so going well you want to change your
life pick a character
and play that character in your mind i
am that character
and
you will become
the characteristics of that character
because that's a program and good actors
they do this and they physically and
behaviorally change
to become those characters you know
is there anything you're working on
right now for manifesting into your life
no i'm loving my life my life is i love
my life i have
no more wishes need to be granted i'd be
just happy where i am right now it's
working beautifully
you know
i'm an old codger you know
and it's near 80 years old no i'm not
that's not my consciousness at all with
that aging is a belief system
oh i'm too old to do that if that's what
you said you have just told that to your
body
and then you will not be able to do that
because you just told yourself i'm too
old to do that
that's what people start to do when they
get older i'm too hot on i go well stop
saying that for god's sakes
because what you're doing is manifesting
a reality of age
i love it well bruce i could talk to you
for days we'll have to do around two
around three or around 43 i don't know
there's some so many ways we can go but
last question you've done so much to
help people you've poured so much love
into people over i mean decades now at
this point with all the work you're
doing if people were to hold you
bruce lipton in their hearts tonight or
their prayers tonight what would you
have them pray for that i'm around long
enough to keep sending out this message
to everybody else on this world and
enjoy it while i'm doing it that's
exactly what my plan is i'm enjoying my
world
and i'm enjoying
waking up the sleeping consciousness
because
when the world when other people change
their belief the world changes
and if i the more people that get the
power of creativity back in their hands
will create a better world than where
the creativity is coming from government
and drug companies and banks and
corporations they're not creating the
world that we want they're creating
their world
their world is self-destructive that's
why we're experiencing a collapse of the
the web of life you know corporations go
ahead take all the oil out of the ground
who cares you know cut the mountains
open take all the coal out you know it's
like
where the hell you think you guys are
you know go back to native americans who
really knew they said this is a garden
we are gardeners
i go
this is a garden and now we perceive it
as well get every hell you want out of
that garden just in there and trample
the crap out of it and grab what you
want i go uh oh no more garden i go
that's where we are
and so it's basically
for people to recognize
that you have had the ability to change
your life when you did fall in love
that's just
a moment of necessary recollection
because i want people to go back and say
so
how was your life after you fell in love
it could have been just a few days it
could have been a week a month a couple
of months a year
unlikely but of honeymoon
even if it was three days of honeymoon i
say here's your life blah blah blah and
then three days
south seas idyllic you know it's
beautiful and then back to ba
i go you did it
the duration of it was only based on the
fact is
is it in your conscious mind or is in
your subconscious mind
have you stopped playing the program
then your conscious mind is in charge
play the program then the subconscious
mind is in charge
look at your life which one do you want
i love it well the man is bruce lipton
the website bruce lipton.com we'll link
it up down in the description below he's
got a newsletter that's free i'm on it
go sign up he's got a membership program
that's like seven bucks a month super
cheap he's got an amazing youtube
channel uh that's educational and fun
with his nephew as well check it out
bruce appreciate the time the energy the
wisdom the humor
all the love thank you
evan i want to thank you for this
opportunity especially because we have
an audience out there
that i think when
empowered which is what our collective
intention is
is to empower them
then the more that they are creating the
more heaven we're all going to
experience on this planet
and when we start to fully express who
we are then that honeymoon is a way of
life and that is one of the most
fabulous experiences why
i've been living the honeymoon for 25
years with my partner why
i got rid of those programs i downloaded
from my mom and dad about how
relationships work because boy they were
dysfunctional and i manifested
dysfunction until
rewrite the program
what's my program heaven on earth baby
here i am
i love it thank you bruce appreciate you
man
evan thank you and again thank our
audience so appreciate it
to see my recent one-on-one with deepak
chopra check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there every
thought you have is a magical lie
how do we live a life with zero physical
or mental weakness